[Musique]
jamais
oui
je suis
daniel boucher travaille sur son nouvel
album et en plus du numérique
il forge à le sortir en vinyle oui ça
serait le fun parce que de toute façon
moi je veux tout l'hérédité mes albums
en vinyle
on dirait que ça donne de la valeur à
notre travail quelque part on dirait que
ça donne de la valeur d'un objet qui
donne de la valeur
je suis les voitures chez les musiciens
québécois
le vinyle est très tendance des artistes
comme louis jean cormier jean leloup et
les cowboys fringants en disques en
vinyle et le vieux rock québécois
disparus et réédité pour la pochette
pour le son et pour la nostalgie est en
train de travailler sur les albums de
manège en étant d'un travaillé sur les
albums de contraction le catalogue
complet d'offenbach
pour la journée du disquaire 2020 du mal
à rééditer son album le cours des jours
even demande des courriels des des
messages sur internet les éléphants
n'avaient d'attachement avec le court
des jo même s'il se vend dix fois plus
de disques compacts les ventes de
vinyles augmente
en 2008 il s'en est vendu 7600 au québec
ce chiffre a explosé en 2016 pour
atteindre 180 milles en 2019
avec ce retour du vinyle même le fou man
show de robert charlebois sorti en 1972
a droit à une réédition avec
reproduction du livret original très bel
album la tête de charlevoix des artistes
qui ont un catalogue importants devront
s'assurer qu'il ya une permanence
de l'offre en ville leur titre mais
attention il n'y a pas beaucoup d'argent
à faire avec le vinyle dit claude
larivée le fu manchu tiré à 500
exemplaires a coûté 35 $ l'unité à
produire l'album est chère à la vente et
je dire qui est extrêmement cher à la
production donc qu'on comprenne c'est
vraiment pour l'expérience et robert
charles hobaugh lui même le sol rend
très heureux de savoir que l'album a été
signé
est-ce que les vinyles restera encore
longtemps la mode daniel boucher demeure
prudent on va peut-être en faire
imprimer sincère je sais pas plus que
sonne peut-être mais je serais surpris
pendant face imprimé mais à moins qu'on
aime il demande ici oui c'est des
primaires
radio canada montréal
[Musique]